الارجنتين اول طرفين نهائي المونديال
بعدما انهت مغامرات كرواتيا الجريئه وقصت
عليها بثلاثيه نظيفه الاهداف جميعها وقع
عليها الاسطوره ميسي سواء بتسجيل او
الصناعه ليوم استمر للنهايه مباراه واحده
تفصلها عن اللقب الاغلى في مشاركته
الخامسه حتى موازر منتخب البرازيل حتى
مجانين رونالدو متابعه اللعبه المنصفون
وصول ميسي الى النهائي هذه المسيره تحتاج
الى تكريمه
ارادت كره القدم ان تحفظ هذا اللقب لتهديه
له في اخر ظهور يكون مشهد النهايه تكريما
لاحد اعظم من روضها في التاريخ على الجانب
الاخر رحله لوكا مودريتش قائد كرواتيا في
كاس العالم انتهت لكنه سينافس على المركز
الثالث مع الخاسر من لقاء فرنسا والمغرب
يوم السبت
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]